So I started saying last Wednesday or Thursday
when it became clear that Joe Biden had an
increasingly clear path to 270 electoral votes
and thus the presidency, that he should immediately
launch a parallel coronavirus task force.
Parallel, of course, to the official White
House task force led by Mike Pence, who has
failed miserably, who has replaced infectious
disease doctors with radiologists who spent
months downplaying the virus and then spent
months claiming that the Trump administration
beat the virus.
Cases got worse and worse and worse.
Well, it's time for adults to have a go at
it.
And the co-chairs of Joe Biden's coronavirus
task force are expected to be Vivek Murthy,
surgeon general under Obama.
David Kessler from the FDA under George H.W.
Bush and Clinton, Rick Bright may be involved,
who was, of course, famously pushed out during
after raising the red flag during this current
administration.
Everybody they have, but rather Kessler and
Murthy have been briefing Biden for months.
Biden is considering many things, including
speaking to governors about mask mandates,
which might be necessary, the way things are
going, scaling up, testing, using the model
of President Franklin Delano Roosevelt to
war production board, according to advisers
who are speaking on the condition of anonymity.
Biden may start calling governors right now
to talk about masks because it's so urgent
and I'm all for it.
The point is, Biden's plan is for all of Americans
to hear the same stuff from the president,
from governors, all levels of government.
And how Donald Trump will react to that, we
don't know.
We did hear late last night that all of a
sudden, Mike Pence will be convening a meeting
of the White House coronavirus task force
today.
Donald Trump still doesn't even acknowledge
that Joe Biden, one, Donald Trump may go absolutely
insane and go get extremely triggered and
lose his mind as Joe Biden starts to simply
take a leadership role on a lot of these issues.
And honestly, my best bet, my my best scenario
is that Biden, Trump, rather, just kind of
slinks off and plays golf for the rest of
his term.
Let Joe Biden get a head start.
And of course, once Joe Biden is in the White
House, he will likely go to Congress and ask
for more money, for testing, more money, for
getting schools and businesses ready to be
in a position to open safely.
And interestingly, Biden is even going to
have subgroups in his task force.
He will have a testing subgroup.
He will have a subgroup, a vaccine subgroup,
and on and on.
He may even bring in a coronavirus czar who
will be certainly far more competent than
Mike Pence running this thing.
Now, I want to warn all of you right now.
Republicans have been mostly silent on debt
and deficit for four years because it's a
political football, and when a Republican
is in the White House, Republicans don't talk
about debt and deficit.
Remember, Trump ran on eliminating on that
national debt.
He's increased it dramatically.
Now that Joe Biden is coming in, just be ready
for Republicans to start up again with how
how will we pay for it?
Can we afford a testing program?
Can we afford a tracing program?
The concern, trolling about the deficit is
going to be used to get in the way of Biden
dealing with the virus.
And I'll go even further.
After downplaying cases and deaths for eight
months, I wouldn't be shocked to see those
same Republicans say on February 1st, maybe
even January 25th.
Look at all these cases under Joe Biden.
Look at all these deaths under Joe Biden,
we just have to be prepared is the point for
stunning hypocrisy to continue and even get
much worse.
Good for Joe Biden for doing this right away.